[Music]
fox news reported recently that google
is in the spotlight after internal
emails show conversations between
employees highlighting a desire to
manipulate search results on the heels
of president trump's controversial
travel ban in order to mute conservative
viewpoints and push ways to combat the
ban
google however denies that this
manipulation was ever implemented even
though the social media giant is clearly
changing search results in other areas
particularly in relation to islam and
jihad
google staffers wrote of rigging
searches to help people combat trump's
travel ban which was designed to prevent
people from jihad hot spots from
entering the u.s overall idea they wrote
leverage search to highlight important
organizations to donate to current news
etc to keep people abreast of how they
can help as well as the resources
available for immigrations as they put
it or people traveling
google employees who learned of this
were thrilled commenting we're
absolutely in excellent initiative and
the like yet now that it has come to
light google claims that nothing was
really done
these emails they say were just a
brainstorm of ideas none of which were
ever implemented google has never
manipulated its search results or
modified any of its products to promote
a particular political ideology not in
the current campaign season not during
the 2016 election and not in the
aftermath of president trump's executive
order on immigration our processes and
policies would not have allowed for any
manipulation of search results to
promote political ideologies
that's what they say but it's clearly
false
google has admitted in the recent past
to manipulating search results back in
july 2017 turkey's anadolu agency
reported that google's first page
results for searches of terms such as
jihad sharia and taqiyya now return
mostly reputable explanations of the
islamic concepts taqiyya which describes
the circumstances under which a muslim
can conceal their belief in the face of
persecution is the sole term to feature
a questionable website on the first page
of results reputable according to whom
questionable according to whom
google was bowing to pressure from
muslims such as the texas imam omar
suleiman who led the initiative to
compel google to skew its results
without considering whether those who
are demanding that the search results be
manipulated in a particular direction
might have an ulterior motive could it
be that those who are pressuring google
wanted to conceal certain truths about
islam that they would prefer that
non-muslims not know
this is a real possibility the islamic
initiative to compel the west to accept
sharia blasphemy laws under the guise of
stamping out hate speech is now
galloping forward and achieving immense
success as i detail in my book the
complete infidel's guide to free speech
and its enemies but of course google
executives would have had to study islam
themselves in order to determine whether
or not these muslims were pressuring
them were misleading them and they did
not of course undertake that study
still
they could have done a bit more due
diligence and made some efforts to
determine whether those being tarred as
hate groups really deserved the label
whether the southern poverty law center
was really a reliable and objective
arbiter of which groups were and weren't
hate groups and whether the information
that google was suppressing was really
inaccurate
instead google swallowed uncritically
everything omar suleiman and the others
said
yet suleiman still wasn't satisfied
anadolu agency continued one leading
activist in favor of google modifying
its results told anadolu agency he
noticed the updated search results and
thanked the companies for its efforts
but said much still needs to be done he
claimed that google had a responsibility
to combat hate-filled islamophobia
similar to how they work to suppress
extremist propaganda from groups like
daish and al qaeda
this should have made google executives
stop and think the islamic state daish
and al qaeda slaughter people gleefully
and call openly for more mass murders
there is no firm evidence that anyone
has ever been killed by so-called
hate-filled islamophobes and the claim
that hamas linked care in the southern
poverty law center make in this anadolu
agency article that this supposed
islamophobic rhetoric has led to a rise
in hate crimes against muslims is
supported by not a scintilla of evidence
sulaiman was equating critical words
with murderous deeds and google should
have realized at that point that he had
an agenda and wasn't being honest
sulaiman
however tried to pose as an impartial
arbiter the anadolu agency article
continues solemn said google should
differentiate between criticism of islam
and hate-filled islamophobia emphasizing
the religion should not be infringed
upon
that wasn't clear he was saying that
there was acceptable criticism of islam
that was not hate-filled islamophobia
but if that's so then the religion can
be infringed upon at least by this
legitimate criticism or if the claim
that islam must not be infringed upon
means that it cannot be criticized why
is that so of islam but not of any other
religion
sulaiman says i don't think google has a
responsibility to portray muslims
positively i think google has a
responsibility to weed out
fear-mongering and hate groups but i
don't want google to silence critique of
islam or critique of muslims
the problem with this is that neither
omar suleiman nor care nor the southern
poverty law center nor anyone else who
has ever said that there's a distinction
between legitimate criticism of islam
and hate-filled islamophobia has ever
identified anyone he thinks is a
legitimate critic of islam who is not
islamophobic
i've written over eighteen books now as
well as thousands of articles and over
sixty thousand blog posts i've attempted
to present a reasonable documented fair
and accurate criticism of islam an
explanation of the jihad doctrine
nevertheless i've been tarred as a
purveyor of hate-filled islamophobia by
groups and individuals that have never
given my work a fair hearing but have
read it only in search of gotcha quotes
they could use wrenched from their
obvious benign meaning in order to claim
i was saying something hateful
and this doesn't happen only to me of
course it happens to anyone and everyone
who dares to utter a critical word about
islam or jihad wherever they are on the
political spectrum the jihad against the
freedom of speech is advancing rapidly
and most people don't even know it's
happening and google despite its denials
is willingly playing along
i'm robert spencer a showman fellow for
the david horowitz freedom center and
director of ghodwatch this video has
been brought to you by the center for
security policy
[Music]